absolute grenze des menschlichen auges
tod bringen der erreger im gepäck und
raketenstart in 3d das sind drei der
fünf dem in den klicks um top 50 die
forscher des astrophysikalischen
instituts der kanaren haben
sensationelles entdeckt in den
aufzeichnungen des 42 meter teleskops
des observatoriums von la palma haben
sie 33 sich über lagen die supernovae
gefunden
dieses spektakuläre bild gibt jetzt neue
rätsel auf wenn ein stern stirbt wird
der gesamte wasserstoff des sterns zu
helium umgewandelt im inneren bildet
sich ein fester kern die kernfusion
stoppt und der stern kollabiert das
äußere material des sterns sturz mit
70.000 kilometern pro stunde auf den
festen kern und wird zurückgeschlagen
eine supernova entsteht der theorie nach
dürfte dann aber nur eine einzige
schockwelle entstehen zitat dieses
medium ist offenbar nicht gleichförmig
verteilt sondern bildet dichte gas
klumpen umgeben von weniger dichten
material die erste super nova reist dann
nur gas aus den außenbereichen dieser
klumpen mit sich sodass genügend dichtes
gras über bleibt um auch die zweite und
dritte super nova schockwelle zu geben
das sagt kamps farina einer der
astronomen des instituts wie die
forscher im fachmagazin monthly notices
of the royal astronomical society
berichten könne diese überlagerung wohl
dennoch nicht von einer einzigen
sternenexplosion stammen drei stück
seien notwendig gewesen
endlich angekommen die sms 0 1 rakete
mit neuen besatzungsmitgliedern für die
internationale raumstation iss an bord
ist wenige tage nach ihrem start vom
weltraumbahnhof baikonur in kasachstan
an der iss angedockt anatoli iranischen
von roskosmos kate rubins von der nasa
und takko jahr um die ski von der japan
aerospace exploration agency stiegen
gesund und gut gelaunt aus ihrer kapsel
aus und wurden mit offenen armen in
empfang genommen wie so ein ankommen im
all aussieht seht ihr jetzt
da hinfahren
foto von der brandy service and space co
vorzuwerfen über diesen sektor
tod bringen der erreger im gepäck
wissenschaftler der universität bern
haben im fachmagazin pop mit eine
besorgniserregende studie zum thema
colistin resistente erreger
veröffentlicht christin ist im falle
einer bakteriellen infektion die absolut
letzte notbremse für die erkrankten kein
anderes antibiotikum hilft so gut gegen
sogenannte multiresistente erreger
christin resistente erreger breiten
schweizer forschern allerdings jetzt
kopfschmerzen im zuge einer studie
analysierten sie 38 stuhlproben von
probanden und probanden die kürzlich in
indien urlaub gemacht hatten dabei kamen
sie zu dem ergebnis dass elf prozent der
getesteten personen co lässt ihn
resistente bakterien mitgebracht hatten
eine verbreitung solcher keime wäre
katastrophal da kein antibiotikum
dagegen wirksam ist und nun zitat die
ansteckung mit cholesterin resistenten
bakterien auf reisen ist ein phänomen
das wir sorgfältig beobachten müssen um
die ausbreitung von solchen
behandelbaren super kamen in der schweiz
zu verhindern
einem land das von diesem problem noch
relativ ungerührt ist so andré denn die
mini jährlich sterben übrigens ungefähr
700.000 menschen aufgrund von
antibiotikaresistenzen also an bakterien
die gegen antibiotika resistent sind
verbreiten sich diese kritischen erreger
würde die zahl der toten wohl deutlich
steigen 3d raketenstart videos von
raketenstart hat man ja schon oft
gesehen hautnah dabei waren aber wohl
die wenigsten heute haben wir für euch
einen kleinen kompromiss gefunden ein
raketenstart video in 3d wer von euch
also eine 3d brille zu hause hat oder
sich eben schnell eine basteln möchte
ihr braucht dazu eine rote und eine
blaue folie kann sich den start der
sojus u rakete mit dem progress m 10 03
transportschiff vom weltraumbahnhof
baikonur in der dritten dimension
ansehen also viel spaß
absolute grenze des menschlichen auges
wie klein können gegenstände oder wie
schwach kann eine lichtquelle sein so
dass wir sie noch ohne hilfsmittel wie
lupen oder mikroskope erkennen können
mit dieser frage haben sich nun forscher
der universität wien beschäftigt zitat
obwohl dies seit 70 jahren untersucht
wird ist bis heute unklar wo die
absoluten grenzen liegen so die
wissenschaftler in einer versuchsreihe
mit 30.000 durchläufen testeten sie das
menschliche auge mit gerätschaften der
quantenoptik bis zur absoluten grenze
sie schossen mit einem photon also einem
lichtteilchen auf das auge und parallel
dazu auf einen verlässlichen detector
die probanden saßen in einem
abgedunkelten raum und sollten zum einen
sagen ob sie licht gesehen haben und
wenn ja ob sie an ihrer aussage zweifeln
oder eben nicht das ergebnis ist
sensationell
über 50 prozent der sichtung waren
korrekt zitat das spricht dafür dass das
menschliche auge tatsächlich imstande
ist ein einzelnes photon zu erkennen
dass es wirklich bemerkenswert und zeigt
bis zu welch erstaunliche effizienz die
evolution die empfindlichkeit der
sinnesorgane vorantreiben kann
in diesem fall bis zur einheit der
physikalischen größe selbst das sagte
ali pascha siri von der universität wie
übrigens zum thema quantenmechanik gibt
es ein tolles hörbuch von harald lesch
einem physiker der wirklich mit leib und
seele und einer menge humor komplexe
inhalte vermittelt das beste daran ihr
könnt das hörbuch von uns geschenkt
haben liegt dafür einfach auf den
hörbuch link hier oben auf dem i oder in
der video beschreibung erstellt euch
dann einen kostenlosen probe account bei
audible und schon könnt ihr in die welt
der quantenmechanik abtauchen also viel
spaß dabei und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lassen wir gerne einen
daumen nach oben und ein kostenloses abo
da und schreibt mir
nachdem ihr euch das hörbuch angehört
habt eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
die hat es euch gefallen ich bin
gespannt und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran